sapete che i giornalisti di repubblica
mission delle dieci domande io non lo
faccio non faccio eccezione questa a
questa regola
suggestioni rapide per entrare nel tema
diciamo
e allora iniziò da quasi a questa questa
fotografia non è photoshoppata diciamo è
una specie di rappresentazione iconica
una specie di derna tonica della
uguaglianza così come la vedo io
cioè siamo san paolo c'è un complesso
molto lussuoso e questa è questa tabella
che vedete sulla sinistra si chiama
paraiso police cioè nel paradiso capite
di ironia delle parole
succede molto spesso più le cose sono
mostruose più le parole si fanno alate e
mi sembra un bel un bel punto da dove
cominciare abbastanza abbastanza
evidente ecco qui questi qua stanno
molto bene sono la piscinetta sul
terrazzo queste quattro anno in una
favela e quindi il 10 pro suggestioni
rapidissima molto più rapide di quelle
che pur costretti a fare i relatori sono
sono queste qua la mia personale diciamo
così alfabetizzazione sulla uguaglianza
parte tanti anni fa quando ho vissuto e
lavorato a new york ha anche beneficiato
del consiglio dell'ospitalità della
nostra prima relatrice nadia urbinati e
allora a quell'epoca nel 1998 è uscito
questo libro che mi fece molta molta
impressione forse era più
impressionabili allora ma anche adesso
che lo considera specie di golden
standard di queste riflessioni di queste
cose il trionfo della meschinità
traducendo insomma fra le tante cose che
diceva questo libro di come si stava
incarognendo diciamo l'america diceva
una cosa che mi è rimasta molto impressa
e che poi ho ritrovata in questo in
questo grafico diceva che fra i sintomi
diciamo dell'incattivimento agli stati
uniti c'era questa questa disuguaglianza
ovvero nel 1998 vedete qui nella parte
più alta
il rapporto fra la dello stipendio di
amministratore delegato e di un
dipendente la stessa azienda era di 500
volte a 1 e parecchio diciamo adesso
siamo verso 350 che significa che questa
questa sala a 360 posta è come se quel
signore che non c'è di quella quella
sedia vuota
lui da solo guadagnare
se come tutti voi diciamo si può dire
che va bene si può dire che forse c'è
qualcosa di sbagliato insomma è quel
rapporto esattamente plasticamente
raffigurato in questa sala una sedia un
signore che non è li guadagna come tutti
gli altri o se volete vedere un altro
modo uno che lavora un giorno guadagna
come come l'altro che lavora tutti i
santi giorni per per un anno e anche ai
giorni nostri ci sono 98 ma i giorni
nostri
questa è questa quali azioni ben
rappresentata da questa da questo
grafico che fa vedere come i 66 membri
della famiglia walton quelli di wal mart
da soli guadagno come il 43 per cento di
tutti gli americani
secondo punto di pil privati non ci sono
persone che da sole valgono come una
nazione io tanti anni fa ho scritto un
libro su bill gates una biografia non
autorizzata e quindi ma rimasta un po
questa nel frattempo mi chiese di
buonissimo e siamo solo contenti quindi
all'epoca era un po meno e sicuramente
comunque la sua fortuna valeva poi
economisti adesso alzare una mano non è
la stessa cosa la ricchezza che il pil
si misura differentemente che oscurano
risparmio maurizio franzini insomma di
tutti gli altri però insomma come
allegoria come dire 2000 solo valeva più
del pil di questi stati
in rosso però non è che anche la crisi a
colpi di tutti nello stesso modo non è
che le cose vanno male per tutti anzi
per alcuni vanno vanno benissimo e qui
c'è un altro grafico abbastanza semplice
quella blu è come aumentato diciamo il
reddito degli amministratori delegati
dal 90 a oggi più 300 per cento quella
gialla
anzi quella rossi arancione siamo tutti
noi cioè sono i lavoratori normali sono
rimasti quasi quasi fermi più 4 a 3 per
cento e la cosa ancora più pressante è
il stipendio minimo federale quello
quello giallo che meno 9 di gara 3 per
cento c'è la gente lavora guadagna meno
come minimum wage adesso di quanto di
quanto facessero all'inizi del 90
e ci abbiamo un problema però perché se
se tutti gli altri diciamo stanno peggio
e i ricchi stanno molto meglio non va
bene per nessuno
questo questo questo grafico l'ho preso
da un documentario di robert reich che è
stato ministro del lavoro sotto clinton
è affatto un documentario piuttosto
suggestivo che siamo in i quali di
parole questa insomma è soltanto una
rappresentazione molto appunto vivida di
come stavano le cose nel 1928 cioè
rispetto il 1 per cento diciamo aveva il
deteneva il quasi un quarto credo di
aver perso questo quasi un quarto dei
redditi totali è esattamente come
successo nel 2007 dava tutto un giro
sapete che dopo il 28 non sono queste le
cose belle diciamo per il mondo quindi
come dire vorremmo evitare che ne
successero uguali cioè disuguaglianze
estreme portano dei risultati piuttosto
brutti e lui spiega rover raicam tutto
punto non calcola che il pil la
ricchezza di un paese e il caso e stati
uniti dipende per 70 per cento dai
consumi la classe media
d'accordo quindi se la classe media ha
di che spende e l'economia va bene
altrimenti siamo nei guai diciamo per
quante ferrari possono comprare i membri
del nuovo per cento non potranno mai
comprare tante macchine quante utilitari
quanto li comprerebbero invece quella
classe media che possono che sono in
grado di farle qui c'è proprio la caduta
diciamo del potere d'acquisto nel 2008
nel 2010 per esempio si va da 85 a 48
dollari insomma è molto evidente come
sono cambiate le cose non per il meglio
siamo a metà non è sempre stato così
appunto negli anni settanta la classe
media stava stava piuttosto bene qui
diciamo introducono alcuni membri della
mia famiglia
come dire un felice esponente della
classe media degli anni 70 e questo
signore quasi alessandro italiano e mio
padre è appunto 24enne piuttosto
sorridente diciamo lavorava in banca era
laureato lavorava in banca
questa mia madre questo sono io questa
mia sorella stefania e siamo in vacanza
perché noi andiamo in vacanza
tutti gli anni e mangiano pesce fresco e
come tutto andava bene adesso le cose
sono cambiate
tra un quarto e un terzo le operazioni
di sportello sono scomparse negli ultimi
anni a causa dell'home banking è una
cattiva notizia quella terribile che è
solo l'antipasto dice lando sileoni
segretario generale della fabi cioè le
cose stanno cambiando la classe media si
sta rimpicciolendo quindi chi la uccise
questa classe ora ci sono due soliti
noti ma è un nuovo indiziato vabbè
quella che si sta alla romanizzazione
potremmo parlare tutto il giorno ma non
è mio compito farlo di un in un libro
recente uno storico ha calcolato che la
delle valutazioni ha fatto perdere solo
in italia 2 viva 6 milioni posti di
lavoro
come dire sono un investimento felice e
chissà forse no
un altro un altro solito sospetto è la
finanziarizzazione dell'economia per cui
appunto ai fini la capitalizzazione di
borsa meno pesa il lavoro nel meglio ha
delle prospettive diciamo nazionali
delle delle aziende il terzo nuovo
l'intruso diciamo di questa uccisione
della classe media e l'automazione punto
che la tecnologia si sostituisca e posti
lavoro non è una novità
però adesso è cambiato qualcosa è
cambiata questa cosa qua lo dicono due
economisti dell'emmeti non libro
piuttosto famoso prima dal dopoguerra
fino a oggi la produttività la linea
sopra quella più scura crescerà di pari
passo con quell'impiego cioè tecnologia
causava più produttività si produceva di
più meglio è però non si perdeva portò
lavoro perché chi perdeva il lavoro
nell'agricoltura ritrovano manifattura
chi perderà il posto alla manifattura
andava nei servizi
poi intorno al 2000 come vedete c'è una
forbice sulle cose sono sono cambiate e
più o meno il momento in cui la
tecnologia nuova diciamo così il
software sempre più intelligente che
sostituiscono anche i servizi che
sostituiscono anche le professioni
creative diciamo hanno cominciato a far
sentire loro il loro effetto
la lista conoscete tutti cioè sono
espandibili agenti di viaggio categoria
ampia descrizione spero che sia una che
siano dire che vadano benissimo però
diciamo complessivamente le cose stanno
cambiando la gente compra i biglietti su
expedia commercianti pensate ad amazon
musicisti napster e altri fotografi
giornalisti ci sono dei software che
funzionano cominciano a funzionare bene
che scrivono articoli senza intervento
umano camionisti google car quella senza
pilota che diventerà una realtà avvocati
traduttori docente a lista è infinita
un esempio che fa capire bene questa
cosa cioè il ruolo della formazione
della tecnologia nella classe media è
questo qua questa azienda che molti di
voi conosceranno
o piuttosto popolare instagram è stata
comprata da facebook per un miliardo di
dollari
e quando è stata comprata impiegava 13
persone tredici persone un miliardo
ognuno di questi lavoratori diciamo
niente mente valeva moltissimo questa
azienda faceva tendenzialmente il lavoro
che una volta faceva questa azienda che
forse conoscete meglio cioè come di
condividere immagini quando la coda che
stava bene costa troppo non è più fra
noi perché fallita e impiegava 140.000
dipendenti 13 a 140.000 un rapporto
molto molto altro non è che tutti sono
riciclati diciamo nella nel come web
designer purtroppo ecco ci siamo quasi
questo nuovo scenario che gli amici
chiamano the winner takes on questo
modello in cui chi vince prende tutto è
abbastanza raccontato bene da questa
coppia di di professori di due
superpotenze intellettuali diciamo che
con con gusto per le camicie abbastanza
discutibile ma insomma sono peter norvig
e se bastano tre fra l'altro se
abbastanza non è uno quelli dietro
all'idea della google car sono due star
dell'informatica hanno fatto tutto punto
una lezione su una piattaforma che siano
a corsera ci aveva avuto quella quel
corso sull'intelligenza artificiale
100.000 centomila studenti
ecco vendita del 100 mila studenti se
due professori arrivano 100 mila
studenti
cosa fanno tutti i professori che non
sono così tanto star o ancora se io
posso andare del numero uno del mondo
peter norvig e sebastian thrun perché
dovrei andare da un bravo professore di
informatica un po meno brillante di loro
no se si è possibile farlo diciamo
online
questo è un tema su cui riflettere
i lavori che non sono distrutti sono
impoveriti
in molti casi a un certo punto a un
certo punto io ho fatto questo
esperimento vedete questo questa
figurina e quello di quella cosa che si
chiamava il turco meccanico cioè un
finto automa già nell'ottocento per cui
c'era un grande scatola e dentro c'era
un omino che faceva finta di esserlo
tono ora una donna c'era qualcuno dentro
che tirare le file in maniera con con
con scarso senso dell'umorismo forze nel
senso di umorismo molto molto nero
amazon ha chiamato meccanica al tar che
questa questa piattaforma per cui chi ha
da fare dei lavoretti può fargli
comprendere il proprio talento
la volete molto banali e soprattutto
molto mal pagati e ho fatto un
esperimento una sera ho fatto ho scritto
tra scritto un biglietto da visita cioè
ho visto le immagini alle altre scritte
come un dattilografo redatta una breve
recensione cinematografica ha tentato di
descrive delle foto astratte con parole
chiave e poche altre cose
tutta questa attività che mi hanno preso
un'ora un onore ha corso e sono stato
ottimista porta anche più di un'ora ho
preso un dollaro 65 centesimi sono molto
molto molto molto fortunato diciamo ecco
tutto questo per dire cosa che insomma
c'è bisogno c'è bisogno di pensarci sia
la gente che non è d'accordo che gente
molto molto cheerleader diciamo della
tecnologia come dire senza se e senza ma
sono tutte posizioni legittime io credo
che dopo 20 anni dalla nascita di
internet diciamo così lascia popolare di
internet e c'è bisogno di ripensare
anche al lato oscuro della forza diciamo
il senso della giornata di oggi che che
finalmente darà il via è di pensare
anche soluzioni ce ne sono varie
possibili con concepibili 1 nel reddito
universale chissà come deve
bisogna vedere delle tasse delle tasse
su quelli che guadagni sia momenti
relativo sempre di meno ci si può
pensare
oppure far pagare la nostra attività
online
c'è chi l'ha detto far pagare i like di
google su facebook se noi facciamo
un'attività digitale è giusto che ci
venga in qualche modo retribuita e per
finire appunto per chi non fosse forte
con la fisiognomica questo un'altra
un'altra idea siamo pericolosi su come
uscire da queste se che l'ha detta molto
bene questo signore che si chiama hanno
avuto evidentemente che avevamo con chip
o più multi multi uso civile ha problemi
con quella di uguaglianza e chiara
questo qua bisogna essere buoni caso
quindi io vi auguro una buona una buona
giornata
grazie all'ora
[Applauso]
a questo punto